strangers rank
their intelligence oh boy we're back
again with another jubilee
and this should be a good one rank your
intelligence right now
wrong hey look at the bell curve so i
pull it up
that's you right there right next to the
the bee you it's okay bees are smart a
lot of people don't know they stay
how do they know how to take the nectar
into the thing and
put it in i don't know how to do that
bees know how to do that [ __ ]
all right why am i talking about bees
okay
okay i wasn't planning to go to college
that wasn't like a goal of mine
my parents were like well you should
apply to at least one college i was like
we'll never get in here
and then i went to yale let me guess
everyone that went
to college think they're way smarter
wait is college university
you call it differently don't you we
brought six people together
to rank themselves based on perceived
intelligence
but do they do an iq test afterwards
that's what i need to know
right let's see how they think and then
what they really are oh please do that
oh that'd be amazing
please god
[Music]
yes oh i'm so excited well done you
billy
[Music]
to be honest i can't do a test in front
of other people i got to do it alone
and if i don't like the result i'll just
redo it
all right shut up but you do your iq
tests on facebook and think you're a
brainiac shut up
[Music]
okay we just like go down and do intros
oh this is
so interesting i work in finance i have
a bachelor's degree
i went to yale i'm tyler i'm 21 i'm a
high school graduate and i work in the
marine corps
i'm kaylee i'm 25 i'm a software
developer i went to ohio university
and i have a bachelor's degree i don't
know how to judge these people the only
way i would judge her is her is that she
you should well now we know our blonde's
dumb all right let's find out
are military people dumb i don't know
let's find out
because everyone knows if there's one
dumb person then they're all done i'm 30
years old
i have my phd in cancer biology and i
work in a biotech industry
grad school i went to university of
south carolina in undergrad i went to
university
of florida hi everybody my name is shawn
i'm 27.
i'm the director of social media for a
company and i also work for
ad agency i got a double major in dance
and cultural anthropology
undergrad i went to loyola marymount
university i graduated with a bachelor's
degree in hybrid recently when i work in
consulting
all younger babies i know this last
thing is eight
okay i'll go i think he went to harvard
hardwood smart big brain and he looks
calm and composed i'm gonna guess sean
is the least smart
and then i don't know about the rest
that's all i got it's an actor
yeah it gives you like years of
experience we need a
maybe it's good to identify what
intelligence means to everybody
i think intelligence is better defined
as your adaptability
and your problem solving skills more we
ain't we
ain't in the unit right now what are you
on about that
maybe that's interesting that people
have different perception though
that's such an expected answer for
someone in the military
education obviously like the education
the stuff you've been through puts a lot
into playing it because it gives you
more resources more
thoughts to draw from the formal
education definitely helps but
i don't think it's in any way essential
so what is the most
ascension so the most essential thing
was probably common sense yeah so for me
personally i think
intelligence is both eq iq and that
common sense
street smart intelligence all of that
combined
interesting all of it combined it's a
good point though
might say is very smart smarter than me
which is extreme
she's extremely smart but
street smart
nah that's where i come in
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's eq i never heard oh
what happened say
[Music]
how did she hear i speak so long
i compliment there's a compliment i
google
baby mri scans don't judge me
eq test what is that emotional
intelligence
what what the [ __ ] my emotions
get out of here people consciously or
unconsciously when they see someone
form an opinion immediately like i'm
sure we all did right away when i saw
i didn't shh
okay maybe i did i told myself maria do
not judge him just by his looks
he could be throwing you off or that's
just who he is
but he can talk to talk and watch
first impressions i would put them at
the bottom only because when i was in
school
all the other people with like the
bright neon colors and stuff they were
typically the ones doing worse in
classes
if we were ranking confidence i'd
definitely put sean it dude very first
place
the definition that we're going with is
the biggest question
i like your definition i like my
definition it combines everything
i feel like i have a good combination of
both like book smart
and street smart so yeah i think i have
some input on that let's
go aspects to intel
great shirt great shirt big brain
maybe big brain i'm just saying it
really goes beyond iq
and eq even those two different factors
went to harward
plunk data university all right don't
really
capture what it really means to be
intelligent i know i'm not
you know from yale i don't have a phd
but
what i lack in those areas i'm able to
still problem-solve and use my own skill
set my emotional intelligence as well as
my social intelligence
besides my education bro they all did
the tests right they should know how
well they did or not
right you get an idea okay i got stuck
on a couple or
right why are they making a case for
themselves just say i did you guys
i nailed it you guys have no chance come
on i feel like i have high like
emotional intelligence like i'm aware of
my surroundings
as i'm starting to think she's the
dumbest one
i just for the record i'm just playfully
saying dumb and smart okay
we i'm okay just so we're clear all
right software developer
my problem solving skills are obviously
top-notch i think i would say
my whole life i've kind of had to fight
to be seen as intelligent i think i'm so
used to having to do that as a woman to
just like step up and be like
i deserve to be here my first job out of
college i was working at a law firm
gentlemen came up to me and said hi um
you don't
look like somebody that would work at a
law firm you look like somebody i'd go
on spring break with
how dare you i i get those comments are
annoying
but at the same time yeah you sign out
so what
i've got the least formal education i
consider myself intelligent that's the
worst thing someone said about you about
your intelligence
oh boy don't make it to videos
be nice to me my mental dedication and
my ability to
adapt and to problem solve what i do in
the marine corps i'm a
seber defense specialist so i think that
by virtue of what i do that already
requires
some amount of intelligence sorry quick
questions so do you think that
only certain people can do your job or
do you think anyone can do your job
uh why don't why don't you ask the
question directly instead of asking him
huh
you that's what you think [ __ ] come on
anyone can be a marine
idiot since they're all dumb bunker
roomies
only certain people you have to take the
asvab before you go into the military
that's uh
not really how much you know but how
well you can learn information and i got
a 94 on that
it's not an amount of how much you study
how much you know you're not going to
really
get better at learning does that make
sense what is this
you need a strong man to open your jar
okay
right here give me the jerk i'll open it
might say it may be smart but i can open
it
i can open that my hands are wet
what is this jar oh no i can't be dumb
and weak
wait you gotta punch it
[Music]
oh my god okay okay maximum strength
wait you don't screw it you screw it
this is ungodly oh my god it was so easy
first try first try
that's good to be smart and strong here
we go martian
anyway where was i oh yeah i'm really
smart okay
you don't get better at learning the
idea that you can get better at learning
is a pretty big signifier of
intelligence i'm very much dyslexic
i have adhd you can definitely get
better at learning
yeah for sure you train your mind bro
come on everyone know this
and i'm on the autism spectrum dyslexia
means that there's a big
gap in comprehension so i was scoring
99th percentile in certain areas and
like
third percentile and others i'll never
be able to learn another language
i took spanish for 12 years and i can
still basically only order a burrito so
i have a question
why did you go to yale and why did you
go to harvard my parents are immigrants
from china
i'm a first generation immigrant as well
and
i got a really interesting group i like
this i like this group of life
i wasn't planning to go to college i
didn't that wasn't like a goal of mine
my parents were like well you should
apply to at least one college and i was
like
i'll never get in here and then i went
to yale
why don't you guys run so i'm gonna
change my mind
uh yeah uh red pants girl dumb
and the rest are fine each other from
one to six including yourself
and give reasons why you're gonna do
what you're doing you gotta go one
no oh hell yeah two three
no wait four five six
no they rank him less i don't think he's
done i really don't
rank you as a six not meaning that
you're not intelligent i also think that
i
no you do you do don't backtrack this
get out of here that's exactly what you
can't do
don't place a lot of value on the
military
what oh
period no that yeah sure get your
get your [ __ ] using there oh yeah
yeah i'd probably do
one two three
four five six i'm sorry
no way does anyone think they're like
either end of the spectrum
i'd say i'm one if nothing else because
i know what i'm about i'm sure
that let's go tyler you're my number one
man you have to rank everyone too
that is so unfair no no no no
i would say one two three
four five six okay that's reasonable
think one
two three four
oh this is going to be so good why do
they all rank him
why why just because he's in the
military like
for me to look past the education part
going to call i have a college leg race
all that for i'm more intelligent you're
just a dummy shooting guns and
i think you learn a lot if nothing else
emotionally
i still think you're smart oh thank you
one two
three oh i can't wait for the result i
hope it's juicy five six
one oh my god parents first generation
going to college humble modest two
me i don't know phd cancer biology
scientists
oh god i mean
you're going last in a biotech company
we make copic 19 testing kits
oh oh she's so unlikable she's extremely
like it's interesting though because
like everyone in this group
are like oh wow but everyone who watches
this is like
what the [ __ ] right how are you guys
sitting there
watching her going oh wow no one is
but in a group where you have to say
something you're like oh
what i just explained modern politics
you're welcome
it has nothing to do with your
background i don't think you really have
the highest eq
out of all of us tyler he ranked last
for me personally because the way he
carries himself he was
ranking intelligence based on his point
of view and not taking it
just like you are by the way they did an
iq test not an eq test
so what are you on about what really
just came down to his body language his
demeanor the way he carried himself the
way he acted towards the group
i would put one what
two um i'm dying to know the results
six so the reason why i put you at
number one
is i think you have the highest not only
eq score out of everybody but the way
you present yourself
as well as being a phd student i think
it's just like a huge thing when i put
myself
six because i feel like i might be the
weakest in terms of actual iq score
hopefully i can make it up and
everything else so i did put my
oh wait did they do different tests okay
well that's great if they did
that'll tell us more uh my mom always
said you know if you're not the smartest
in the room you got to be the best
dressed in the room and you got a chance
so don't worry about it
however if you can't be me i definitely
think
tyler unfortunately his way of thinking
is linear and i think intelligence is
almost like a sphere
it's a picture and right now he's only
coloring with one color then
you know with the rainbow so they all
hate it number one
thank you down
who got the
sure i think that i sort of
expected to be ranked a little bit lower
at first
glance and first interaction with me
it's hard everyone judges me how
intelligent i am it's hard to tell how
intelligent anybody is
is anyone upset with where they're
standing i think it makes sense that i'm
down here like the guy who graduated
from high school and then joined the
military he probably wouldn't be
like high up on there if i wasn't they
all criticized his demeanor too but he
took that
so well as well like what i don't i know
that's not in his entire demeanor and
they probably cut out a lot but still i
would have also ranked myself among the
lowest
i do feel like but bro you you did rate
yourself the highest
what are you on about now what the [ __ ]
there might be a prejudice acting in
terms of ranking
you okay i was thinking highly but i
agree with the ranking
i think you probably are the most
intelligent out of all of us i would
feel
weird placing you there and not
acknowledging the dynamics
in which we did so well you just made it
really weird by pointing it out
right you could you all thought he was
the smartest
you have to point out but you're asian
and i have to say it and there's a
stereo like what
shut up i don't get this stuff
i wonder if they knew that they had to
take an iq test after they rated each
other because if they didn't know
this makes this even juicier uh at least
i'm hoping i'm hoping for a payoff right
now
i literally thought when you said to
open the computer we're gonna look at
social media
i didn't think an iq test would be part
of it oh she's done
she's kind of expecting no intelligence
you know an iq test
it's not that far off the wrong
possibility so number one is raymond
number two would be kaylee
number three will be tyler and number
four would be
shera number five is shawn and number
six is maria
oh she sit down this holy [ __ ]
[Music]
i know
yes yes
you're dumb you're so dumb you thought
you were smart but you're so
stupid look at you i thought we were
gonna look at social media
i think that yes
yes the best pay-off
it would have been better if tyler was
one man still yeah
oh i am very smart
anyway let's get it
let's get the reaction oh
something i don't think it's
intelligence it's definitely testing
something
that's what people say now known to be
flaw well
now they're really flawed and that's why
the military guy is uh
better than me but it really flies has
got a lot of issues with it
odd and like based on incorrect samples
let's hear it red
pen there's two questions on that test
dislikes yeah okay they are usually uh
reading questions yes
but you're just making excuses okay you
already mentioned automatically
basically can't answer
yes but you can all usually in iq test
you can just move on further
right to the more complicated questions
it's fine okay
sure if you studied for an iq test you
would do a lot better
yeah i that's a good point that's a good
point
if it's to measure your intelligence and
you can uh sort of
get a somewhat of a grasp or how they
function you can definitely
perform better and if you're supposed to
measure your intelligence
yeah but then maybe it is a thing where
you have to do it a couple times to get
a decent accuracy
anyways are just one aspect or one way
to measure intelligence
it's really on a spectrum what
constitutes somebody as intelligent
before this all i knew about iq tests is
that they existed
and the i stands for intelligence i've
never looked into iq tests before
coming here today i'm saying the eq that
was the first time i've ever heard that
term in my life
coming yesterday wait is that the first
iq test he did and he got there that's
not bad
it's not just your iq it's your eq it's
your common sense it's street smarts
sure it is some type of metrics similar
to
an act score is a metric for getting
into college but there's more to that
person
oh it isn't it's so much more you're so
much more than ever
[Music]
i'm so happy because i think the best
video you know
i think an iq test is a good indicator
to see how people
handle pressure but i think that's
easier to make sense
in our heads that oh you're smart and
you're not smart definitely don't think
it's the best metric
i've been exposed to tests like these
probably
more than most people here that already
gives me an unfair advantage this is my
villain redemption arc and climbing up
the water
yeah let's go oh that was amazing
10 out of 10. so juicy it tastes so good
in belly
i feel so good right now phenomenal
huge let's just watch that bit again
where she yaps about her [ __ ]
degree sorry quick question so do you
think that
only certain people can do your job or
do you think anyone can do your job
because no not anyone can do my job
clearly because i'm so smart oh wait you
weren't
oh oh no oh no oh
two me i don't know phd cancer biology
scientist
i work in a biotech company we make
copic 19 testing kits stuff like that
they make testing kits
oh my god oh okay i gotta stop it
it's getting a little much
thank you for watching smash like
subscribe see you guys tomorrow next
video then bye
[Music]
i got something something for
even ones that i can't see just download
it for free
for free download
i got something for you
[Applause]
you